we already know that the derivative with
respect to x
of tangent
of x
is equal to
the secant of x squared which is of
course the same thing as 1 over
cosine of x squared
now what we want to do in this video
like we've done in the last few videos
is figure out what the derivative of the
inverse function of the tangent of x is
or in particular let's see if we can
figure out what the derivative with
respect to x
of the inverse tangent of x is and i
encourage you to pause this video and
use a technique similar to the one or
very close to the one that we've used in
the last few videos to figure out what
this is
well let's set y equal to the inverse
tangent of x y is equal to
inverse
tangent of x
that is the same thing as saying
that the tangent of y
the tangent of y is equal to
x all i've done you could kind of think
of it is i've just taken the tangent of
both sides right over here and now we
can take the derivative of both sides
with respect the derivative of both
sides with respect to
x
and on the left hand side we can just
apply the chain rule derivative of
tangent of y with respect to y
is going to be secant squared of y which
is the same thing as 1 over
cosine of y
squared i like to write it this way it
keeps it a little bit simpler at least
in in my brain but when we're applying
the chain rule it's going to be the
derivative of tangent of y with respect
to y times the derivative of y with
respect to x
times the derivative of y
with respect to x and on the right hand
side
the derivative of x with respect to x
well that's just going to be equal to 1.
and so we get if we want to solve for
the derivative of y with respect to x we
just multiply both sides times the
cosine of y squared and we get the
derivative of y with respect to x is
equal to
cosine
of y squared and like we've seen in
previous videos this isn't that
satisfying because
i've written the derivative of y with
respect to x as a as a function of y but
what we're really interested is writing
it as a function of x and to do that we
need to express this somehow in terms of
the tangent of y and the reason why the
tangent of y is interesting is because
we already know that tangent of y
is equal to x so we can rewrite this
using a little bit of trigonometric
identities then we can with tangent of y
we can substitute all the tangent of y's
with an x so let's see if we can do that
and this seems a little bit tricky to
introduce a tangent of y we'd want to
have a sine
divided by a cosine that's what tangent
is and this is just a straight up cosine
squared y so this is really going to
take a little bit more experimentation
than at least some of the other
than the last few examples we've done so
one thing we could do is we said hey
let's just divide by one dividing by one
never hurt anyone so we could say that
this is the same thing
this is the same thing as cosine squared
y and i'm really doing this to to see if
i can start to express it as some type
of a rational a rational expression
which might involve at some point a sine
divided by cosine and i could have a
tangent so let's divide by one
but we know from the pythagorean the
pythagorean identity that one is equal
to sine squared of y plus cosine squared
of y and so let's write that or we could
write cosine squared of y
plus sine
squared of y once again why was i able
to divide by this expression well this
expression by the pythagorean identity
which really comes out of the unit
circle definition of trig functions this
is equal to 1. so i have not changed the
value of this expression
now what makes this interesting is if i
want to introduce a sine divided by a
cosine i could just divide the numerator
and the denominator by cosine squared so
let's do that let's multiply
1 over cosine or let's divide the
numerator by cosine squared of y and
divide the denominator by cosine squared
of y or multiply each of them by 1 over
cosine squared of y and what's that
going to give us well the numerator
these characters are going to cancel
you're just going to have a 1
and in the denominator this times this
that's just going to be equal to 1
and then you're going to have sine
squared
sine
squared y
over
over
cosine squared y and this is this is the
goal that i was trying to achieve i have
a sine divided by cosine squared so this
right over here this is the same thing
actually let me just write it this way
let me
let me write it this way this is the
same thing
as sine
of y
over
cosine of y
cosine of y
whole thing squared which is of course
the same thing as 1 over 1 plus tangent
of y
tangent of y squared this is equal to
this now why is that useful well we know
that x is equal to tangent of y
so this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to
1
1
over 1 plus tangent of y is equal to x
x squared
x
squared which is pretty exciting we just
figure out the derivative of y with
respect to x so the derivative of this
thing with respect to x is 1 over 1 plus
x squared so we could write that right
up here so this is going to be equal to
1
over 1 plus
x squared
and
we
are
done